in a last-ditch election effort green
party candidate annalena berbock tries
to convince voters that she is best
suited to become germany's leader
targeting mainly young people like lucas
weidinger who feel disgruntled by the
status quo and are calling for change i
had some contacts with
the classical more classical older
parties and i i was a little bit
disappointed because i thought like
that that's not how i want to play
politics right and that's not i don't
feel that i really can make a difference
i can only participate in continuing the
same same thing over and over
climate change social justice and
equality are among top concerns for a
generation that grew up in the air of
globalization and the internet the youth
represent less than 15 percent of the
electorate and among them first-time
voters who have known no other leader
than angela merkel but they are trying
to have an impact on the outcome of the
election
they are the so-called miracle
generation one that mostly thinks the
outgoing chancellor wasn't progressive
enough
and they've grown more demanding
maintaining pressure on the streets with
climate protest groups like the friday
for future movement
this is also their last ditch attempt to
make their voices heard less than 48
hours ahead of what rifke lambrecht
calls a historic election
she has put her future on hold saying
there are more pressing issues to be
dealt with first exactly because our
future is in big danger actually if we
are not putting our
studies on hold for example now to go on
the streets to protest
to try our best to change something then
my studies probably won't help me in 50
years anymore because we will have
floods and
war and lots of refugees so the 60-plus
people will decide about our future
so it's so important to convince the old
generation to vote for the young
generation somehow
this has pushed politicians to listen
and address the concerns of young people
says vasily goload he is the co-host of
machiavelli a popular podcast that links
rap and politics
some of the candidates took part in his
show including center left social
democrat leader olaf schultz they need
the young people because they see that
older people also start to think about
the following generations there is
pressure there is pressure from the
streets there is pressure from the young
generation on the streets there is
pressure from young journalists there is
pressure from
musicians so i think in in the whole
society we see that there is a shift
there is a change and
probably we will also see this change
after the election in many ways angela
merkel has shaped german youth they are
a minority of voters but in this tight
race could emerge crucial to whoever
reaches the finishing line first
abdel hamid al-jazeera cologne germany